[Musica]
[Applauso]
se avessi avuto una stampante 3d
immaginate leonardo nel suo laboratorio
avesse avuto a disposizione questa
tecnologia
leonardo sicuramente l'uomo il genio ma
guglielmo marconi che è un mio
conterraneo amava dire non credete
all'esistenza dei geni esistono solo
persone tenaci quindi probabilmente
leonardo così come vogliamo marconi
erano tenaci tenace lo sono anch'io nel
mio piccolo ovviamente non come loro non
ho la loro caratura però vi racconto una
breve storia la storia inizia in questo
posto e l'officina di famiglia dove
facciamo macchine automatiche speciali
l'iran 1980 ero circa 12 anni e mio
padre mi disse un giorno sai se vuoi il
mio posto il suo posto era in ufficio
primo piano devi farti tanta esperienza
usa un altro termine ovviamente però
dice devi farti tanta esperienza giù i
sotto in officina ho detto beh allora
almeno utilizziamo l'estate quando non
vado a scuola per cominciare a fare
questo percorso più ne faccio prima
forse prima ci arrivo lui non aveva
fretta di mollare intendiamoci però
intanto ho fatto il mio percorso e dopo
aver fatto diversi lavori interni e
officina quindi partendo dal magazzino
fatto la logistica ho fatto tante altre
cose è anche gli uffici quant'altro ho
capito che dovevo crescere il mio mio
bagaglio la mia cassetta degli attrezzi
doveva avere altri strumenti colgo
l'occasione una sfida e anche qui c'è
voluto un po di tenacia e mi trasferisco
in america per un anno lavoravo gratis
di giorno presso un'azienda dove faceva
uno stage formativo e alla sera andavo
al college new page
quando sono tornato a casa queste 94
sono tornata a casa volevo cambiare il
mondo lo volevo proprio ribaltare
completamente non era esattamente come
l'avevo pensata perché era molto più
difficile soprattutto quando devi
portare in aziende che sono vecchie
perché hanno comunque una struttura che
è nata tanti anni prima delle novità non
sempre ci riesce con la velocità con cui
le vuoi introdurre però non mi fermo
quindi un giorno mi capita di con un mio
caro amico di vedere una tecnologia con
lui e mio padre ovviamente in società
che risolto finanziatore sostanzialmente
iniziamo a fare simulazioni virtuali
concimati dimenticati circa un anno
prima ma questo non lo sapevo solo dopo
livello storico era nata la pixar quindi
non abbiamo fatto altro che prendere una
tecnologia dei videogame e applicarla al
mondo dell'industria in questo settore
ci siamo applicati su diverse grandi
grossi e aziende e una di queste mi ha
dato l'opportunità di toccare per la
prima volta con mano un oggetto stampato
in 3d e avevo già sentito nominare
queste tecnologie ha saputo quando in
america dove un po studiato però non
aveva ancora toccato questo oggetto non
capivo un bene come poteva funzionare
nei origine pensate che si chiamava
stereolitografia neanche stampa 3d cosa
è successo che a questo punto mi sono
ritrovato nell'azienda di famiglia a
dire beh ma quello che io adesso faccio
quello che vedete lì in alto quindi sono
tre particolari meccanici che compongono
uno stesso pezzo che si chiama piegatore
come posso fare a mollare il metodo
produttivo tradizionale e passare alla
stampa dice posso farlo eco nomico c'era
un percorso a fare quindi ho dovuto fare
dei ragionamenti delle analisi con i
tecnici e quant'altro e quindi ho deciso
che avrei iniziato nel 2011 un cambio
tecnologico in favore del metal abiti
perché perché col metodo consiste non ho
usato molta fantasia il mio cognome e lì
ci sono gli oggetti che voi vedete sopra
e stampati in 3d ovviamente in metallo
quindi io non avevo più tre oggetti con
le viti il montaggio e la distinta e
quant'altro ma avevo un unico oggetto
che uscire dalla stampante come poterlo
fare e ovviamente dovevo fare una
ricerca devo capire quale le tecnologie
e le tecnologie erano la portata di
un'azienda meccanica perché ovviamente
era sicuramente alla portata di aziende
che fanno aerei piuttosto che euro space
cioè dove i budget sono diversi ma
l'azienda meccanica alla fine deve far
quadrare i conti e quindi mi sono un
attimo ingegnato e qualche anno dopo nel
2016 dopo un po di
percorsi di analisi di quello che non le
tecnologie che si trovavano sul mercato
abbiamo deciso in famiglia che visto che
facciamo anche in automatiche man che
era meglio di buy e quindi ci siamo
fatti questa macchina ovviamente anche
qui tenacia never give up andare a fondo
e cercare di capire questa è la
stampante 3d in questo caso stiamo
stampando il nostro gadget che diamo ai
nostri clienti che sono i tortellini
vengo da bologna che poteva stampare
quindi mi sono un attimo ingegnerizzato
e visto che sony non ce l'abbiamo
chiamato tortellino con likely finale
andiamo avanti quello vedete qua in
basso sulla destra poi ci siamo fatti
anche in una realtà che andava anche di
moda a sinistra come potete vedere ci
sono le torri le due torri di bologna e
in mezzo i pezzi meccanici perché in
realtà quello era l'obiettivo il resto
fa solo capire qual è la capacità a
livello produttivo di questa tecnologia
quindi sicuramente
può fare veramente la differenza ma
torniamo un attimo ragionamento ma e
poi cos'è successo cioè quella è stata
la molla che ci ha fatto arrivare a
quello che è il nostro più grande
successo cioè la stampante 3d per ottone
io vado presso un cliente che di brescia
caro imprenditore che stimo moltissimo e
vi presento la stampante di per pericoli
per acciai per i nostri luisa bene bella
fantastica come ma lo fai l'ottone io ho
detto non agorà però se va da casa e
cerco di capire come si fa
magari trovo il materiale perché il
problema era trovare il materiale di
origine per poterlo processare ci
possiamo provare in realtà lui sapeva io
no ma lui sapeva che era una domanda
quasi impossibile ma io non lo sapevo e
quindi ci ho provato lo stesso e poi
comunque avrei preso anche come sfida a
questo punto due anni di tentativi di
prove di ricerca scientifica in
collaborazione con l'uscita di modena
con dei tecnici dei ragazzi che sono
fantastici veramente a un team
incredibile è arrivati a realizzare la
prima stampante tipper ottone al mondo
quindi un primato tutto italiano made in
pontecchio marconi a destra vedete un
oggetto sinistro c'è la classica valvola
quindi che la volée rubinetti questi
secondi va infatti in ottone a destra ci
sono anche oggetti come quelli più qui
di fianco uno può fare una fibbia può
fare qualsiasi cosa in ottone e quindi
non ha solo un uso industriale così come
linux anche l'ottone può avere usi non
industriali
andiamo a leonardo perchè prima vi ho
parlato di leonardo e se avessi avuto
una stampante 3d immaginate leonardo con
una stampante che di in plastica ok
avrebbe potuto prima di andare a
costruire la sua magnifica scala
provarla quindi avrebbe potuto stamparla
piccolina è vero e se magari siano dei
difetti era bravino anche di difetti non
ce n'è mai visti in quel che ha fatto
però per la mobilità dall'altra parte
aveva anche la catapulta poteva anche
provare se funzionava magari doveva
dimensionare di densità diversamente
alcuni pezzi oppure addirittura l'uomo
un uomo vitruviano lo poteva anche
simulare in stampa 3d oppure poteva
andare verso quello che era un'esigenza
di oggi ma immaginate che poteva essere
un'esigenza di allora quindi poteva
creare delle mascherine poteva creare
degli strumenti degli attrezzi e dopo
avrebbe ovviamente fatto il passo
successivo
ma qui stiamo parlando una stampante in
plastica se l'avessi avuto in acciaio
magari avrebbe potuto costruire per il
suo automa cavaliere questo è stata
fatta in acciaio la cotta di maglia ok
quindi avrebbe potuto costruire degli
oggetti che andavano direttamente sul
campo quindi andavano diretta ma anche
degli strumenti poteva costruirci degli
ex degli atleti speciali
perché vi parlo soprattutto di un
generale di stampa 3d che ho fatto dalla
plastica agli acciai all'ottone perché
la stampa 3d è un mercato incredibile
che si sta sviluppando noi siamo in
basso a sinistra questa è la
progressione che ha nei prossimi dieci
anni quindi c'è un partito del mio 19
2029 queste cose significa che in realtà
sono nuove opportunità è un mercato che
crescerà in maniera spaventosa e ognuno
di noi avrà a che fare con questa
tecnologia direttamente o indirettamente
perché lo vuole o non lo vuole adesso
alcuni fanno le protesi in stampa 13
fanno i denti stampa tv e non è che tu
vai dal dottore dice mai fatto in 3d
normale no te lo dice di lui e lui il
dottore vedere il concetto è vida nuove
opportunità di da nuove professioni
quindi io quello che mi auguro è che vi
avvicinate a questa tecnologia
avvicinarsi come regalati viene stampa
3d una stampante piccolina regalatevi se
non a voi anche qualcuno dei vostri
familiari avanti un nipote un figlio
qualcuno e poi cominciate a conoscerla
veramente con poche un entry level non
c'è niente di incredibile però con
continuate a conoscere queste tecnologie
perché è veramente importante che voi
capite che il futuro questa tecnologia
sarà una delle trilogie incredibilmente
per ponderante in tutto quello che fate
in tutto quello che il vostro sviluppo
altra vita questo perché perché così
come è successo per me che non ho
conosciuto questa tecnologia per
un'esigenza è cercato di capire cioè
cercando di immaginarsi un futuro e mi
ha cambiato letteralmente la vita e la
vita della mia azienda
spero che lo faccia altrettanto per voi
quindi quello che vi dico è che vi
auguro che che abbiate questo è un
messaggio come un incitamento a studiare
ad approfondire ed essere curiosi tenaci
quindi mai mai mollare è la parola
d'ordine la tenacia come diceva marconi
non crediate la gente dei geni e la
tenacia quella che fa la differenza
quindi io dico esce il nuovo leonardo
fossi tu grazie
[Applauso]